Film Courage: Steve in an interview with the
Sundance Institute you said you believe there
is no financial incentive to draw the documentary
process out past a year but obviously this
[filmCRIME + PUNISHMENT]took four years
to make. I’m wondering how are you able
to put in four years of time and not run out?
Or did you run out of money several times
and have to apply for grants?
Stephen Maing, filmmaker ofCRIME + PUNISHMENT:Yes,
I think most people working in non-fiction
are finding themselves in situations that
are shooting for years in order to prove to
funders that they have a credible story or
kind of like a proof of concept on hand. You
hear it many times, you submit grant applications
or to funders and they’ll sayWell, come
back when you have more, this looks really
interestingtothe point where people want
rough cuts of work. It’s really a difficult
path to finish an independent documentary
because you are expending all of your personal
savings or resources. Everybody is accruing
(or most people are accruing) massive amounts
of personal debt on credit cards and what
not and so it’s very hard to justify.
But yet when you feel like you are finding
yourself in the crux of a kind of, perhaps
never-before-seen story or access to individuals
who have not had their stories told, that’s
a compelling reason to findanyreason to
continue shooting. Luckily to be able to freelance
in film for other projects was thankfully
a way to sustain myself when times were tight.
And then ultimately I was able to get funding
thankfully from these really amazing organizations
and individuals.